uh glenn greenwald
who is i always thought of him as a
leftist left-wing journalist but he said
some things now that the wright really
likes he put together a phenomenal
super cut of of probably my least
favorite host on msnbc i find her to be
the most grating and the most dishonest
and the most strident nicole wallace
nicole wallace on msnbc has the audacity
to accuse conservatives of spreading
misinformation here is just a sliver
of the kind of misinformation you see
specifically from her
just one woman on just one network msnbc
donald trump to now investigate a
conspiracy theory about kovic coming
from a lab in wuhan this theory needs to
be investigated which is what president
biden is doing hunter biden's laptop
reveals emails we shouldn't look at it
as anything other than a russian
disinformation operation the hunter
biden laptop material is genuine the
murder of a police officer officer brian
stiknick was killed in the line of
duties they beat a capitol police
officer to death officer signick died of
natural causes the steele dossier it may
be dirty but it ain't fake
obviously the sealed i see is
discredited by far actually i mean this
is the lunatic response to what is a
very rational evidence-based fact-based
investigation fbi pleads guilty to
doctoring email what the report shows is
something that won't be surprising to
people that have spent a lot of time in
the federal government the report left
former officials aghast the fbi is
exonerated today it doesn't vindicate
anyone at the fbi who touched this they
are all absolved of any wrongdoing the
activities we found here don't indicate
anybody the trump administration cleared
peaceful black lives matter protesters
so the president could take a photo in
front of a church we did not find
evidence that federal agents used cs gas
this goes on for minutes this go and
this is just one little cut that one
journalist made about one
of the establishment propagandists on
just one of the establishment propaganda
networks just one
and i know if you're listening to this
show you probably have a healthy
skepticism of the establishment media
but even i
grizzled
jaded as i am watching that back to back
to back to back even i was shocked
the lies
that just just this one woman on just
this one network is spreading
and the crazy part is
they all do it
they all do it it's not just her and
it's not just that network
it's all of them
and they do it all the time and the
crazier part is tonight people even if
they saw that clip
tonight people are going to go home
or they're going to be walking in the
airport more likely if they're watching
cnn or msnbc and they're going to watch
that and the people in the in the
clothing with the serious faces are
going to go there and they're going to
say a bunch of bs again and a lot of
people are going to believe it
this is why this is why i don't
give any credence to the elon thing
i don't know whether elon propositioned
to masseuse or not
i i'm not even particularly interested
in this alleged incident that happened
six years ago
because
once you see it you can't unsee it
once you see
that the establishment press
are not there to report the news once
you see that the establishment press
have no regard for truth and they
actually seem to have a pretty strong
contempt for truth
when you see that they are only there to
advance
the democrat party line the liberal
political line the left the
establishment use whatever word you want
you
you become so repulsed
you become you it's even sort of
depressing because we all wish that we
could live in that time that we were
told existed in the past though it
probably never really did exist where we
could trust our newsmen where we all
just we listen you're entitled to your
own opinion but you're not entitled to
your own facts okay and we can all agree
on some basic things no we that doesn't
exist that doesn't exist the
institutions that are most demanding of
our trust are the most corrupt
and so i don't believe a damn word these
people say and every time one of them
parrots some line about how bad elon
musk is
my admiration for him increases
my my likelihood of supporting him
increases
significantly right now go to
dot altoira.com slash michael you know
when there are fluctuations in the
market when things go down a little bit
that can frequently be the time to buy
they call it buying the dip do you own
any bitcoin ethereum cardano or other
cryptocurrency well with an alto crypto
ira you can trade crypto like bitcoin
and avoid or defer the taxes this is the
key a lot of people are interested in
getting
into crypto and to start investing in
crypto but don't do it in a way where
you're going to get punished on the tax
end do it in a tax advantaged retirement
account altos crypto ira is the easy way
to get crypto into an ira you trade all
you want without that tax headache you
create an account in as little as a few
minutes you can start with as little as
10 bucks and there's no setup charges
you get secure trading 24 7 through
alto's integration with coinbase they've
got industry leading security the
advanced encryption standard for wallets
and private keys multiple ways to fund
your account cash contribution a
rollover 401k pretty much anything you
want open an alto crypto ira account
with as little as 10 bucks today alto
ira.com michael that's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com m-i-c-h-a-e-l
start investing in crypto today altoira
dot com slash michael i'm glad you like
that clip now
very important you've got to smash and
ring and click and do the doodad and hit
the gizmo and subscribe to the michael
knowles show you will get all of the
notifications and if youtube doesn't
give you all the notifications head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast for free subscribe do it right
now i'll wait
okay good subscribe the michael knowles
show leave a five star review see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]